bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
mot sur rt france est ce que vous pensez
que ce nouvel outil testé par twitter
peut-être à efficace
enfin pour lutter contre les infos que
ce n'est des fausses informations
maintenant je reste un peu circonspect
sur la leaf est positif que ça que ça
pourrait générer et surtout les
capacités de twitter à pouvoir
réellement lutter contre la fausse
information pourquoi parce que donc une
fois qu'on aura signaler les faits qu
news qui va ensuite géré le pollen
streeter et comme on sait que les
systèmes de modération de twitter sont
quant à elle particulièrement
défaillant depuis l'origine même s'il ya
eu quelques légers progrès
l'intervention humaine qui va déterminer
si les signalements d'une fausse
information qui constitue réellement une
fausse information une fac news qui va
qui va vraiment prendre la décision et
qui aura à ce système de check de
vérification que la france information
l'information
et je doute quand même la capacité de
twitter de quoi le faire sur tout ce que
je crains c'est que ce nouveau bouton ne
soit qu'une arme complémentaire des
trolls à pouvoir éventuellement mettre à
mal nos opposants ou
quelqu'un qui n'est pas de leur avis en
inondant un twitter d'un
défaut d'information
derrière eux
le compte en question et quand on sait
qu'il n'y a pas véritablement de
par rapport à cette sanction
à voir mais en tout cas
vérification
3 parce que si l'on comprend bien cette
nouvelle option il s'agirait donc aux
utilisateurs
de signaler ces contenus s'est fait que
news plutôt qu à des modérateurs du
réseau social lui même comment la france
et le droit social et le droit français
en particulier de lutte aujourd'hui
contre la désinformation
certain nombre d'outils
existe toujours et qui constitue une
arme puissante sur ces cette information
alors on a ensuite la alors la loi vie
avait essayé de mettre en place un
certain nombre d'outils elle a été
retoquée par le conseil constitutionnel
mais au moins on a un certain nombre de
la loi veil news qui avait qui est
intervenu demande du président la cour
notamment pour contrer un certain nombre
de médias dans le monde
à ma connaissance pas eu énormément de
suites concrètes à la condamnation du
questionnaire
période électorale mais on va bientôt y
arriver donc je pense qu'elle va être
finalement réactivée
on a aujourd'hui un certain nombre
d'outils pour lutter contre la montre la
désinformation le la seule difficulté
c'est de savoir réellement qui y est un
docteur pour décider qu'une information
est ou non fausse ou
vérité
ne pourrait y avoir normalement
fonctionné cette fausse information si
on laissait les clés du camion aux
réseaux sociaux comme c'est aujourd'hui
manifestement le cas en la matière
néanmoins twitter aujourd'hui moi je
reste comme c'est très circonspect par
rapport aux capacités pratiques de tri
de pouvoir gérer véritablement soutien
ou non il faut informations qu'elle est
aujourd'hui le noir il existe le droit
impose
une forme d'entente 8 heures un certain
nombre de vérifications peter
aujourd'hui à aider quand même largement
défaillante par rapport à cette
obligation on le voit un petit diamant
aujourd'hui donc il met en place le
nouvel outil très bien maintenant doit
faire ses preuves et je pense qu'ils
font il faut véritablement est très
attentif et sion de fausses informations
soient signalés et qui correspond à
la liberté d'expression
ce qui malheureusement mais
[Musique]
dans les prochains jours
utilisation
d'un taux dernier mot assez rapidement
si vous le voulez bien que les autres
solutions voyez vous pour lutter contre
l'effet cno aujourd'hui
il faudrait que chaque saison se dote
d'un véritable service de vérification
des informations à des risques
à des médias on va dire sérieux et ben
ali à des médias soit sale fric il
faudrait vraiment que oui il est le des
moyens et moyens humains les moyens
l'algorithmique parce que tout est bon
aussi
méritoire décès
il faut vraiment que ça soit nourrie par
des informations sérieuses pour
déterminer ce qui est ou non de fausses
informations et si on au quai rend
compte qu'on est à un recours lorsque
par exemple sur mon compte je mets des
informations tirées blog voici quelques
idées dans ce cas mettant et sa
formation que je puisse moi ne défendra
s'il
est que je veux produire l'information
vérité est qu'on ne peut pas mon compte
de manière
merci beaucoup pour votre regard thierry
vallat avocat au barreau de paris